i'm here with ivan tashev
a principal software architect at
microsoft research
he's known as the brains or at least the
ears at microsoft
and you're behind the acoustic
breakthroughs in the original connect as
well as
the connect on xbox one um and other
products like round table
uh microsoft automotive and you worked
on the microphone array support that
started with vista
yeah you shipped a lot of products uh
for a researcher
i have been live here for a long time
how long have you been at microsoft 15
years
and so you originally came from bulgaria
that's correct and what was the path
that led you here to microsoft
at that time i was assistant professor
in the technical university of sofia my
alma mater actually i have worked for
two companies only
technical university of sophie and
microsoft
and at some point i was tempted to
switch from academia to industry
and to see okay it's good to teach
students and go to make a nice and cool
theoretical work
can this thing work in reality can we
make some of the algorithms
which are easy to derive on paper to be
part of an industrial device
to make the transition from algorithms
from micro for microphone arrays to
algorithms for
manufacturable microphone arrays in
quantities
so explain what the difference is
between a microphone array
and a regular microphone so a regular
microphone is one point in the space
where we pick the sound
a microphone array contains at least two
in the connect case four microphones
like this
and those four microphones give us the
sense of direction
direction so we can combine the signals
from the four channels in a way
to make the microphone ready to listen
towards given direction
and to suppress the sounds coming from
other directions
which means that at the end the
resulting
uh effect is that we get one channel of
a
better microphone high directional
but we can electronically steer the
direction we can listen to
we can electronically place a note
towards a competing sound source
you can electronically steer the null so
at the salsa result
we adaptively are getting the best
possible
sound from the desired direction
minimizing the noise coming from other
directions
and so you can tell where in space a
sound is coming from how accurate is
that
so this technology is called sound
source localization we have it
in kinect and in xbox one
because we have to know where to point
the beam
and the precision is three four degrees
which is sufficiently
to pinpoint the beam the beam inside the
mouth
at four meters distance and how does a
human work so well with just two
microphones
a lot of cpu first we have two
microphones which is important
so it's a microphone array it's not a
single point
and second we have a substantial amount
of cpu power between the two microphones
it's a hundred billion neurons
a computing power we will not have for
our dual processing
in foreseeable future yeah it'll be a
little while
and what are some of the hardest noises
to remove
so in kinect we have
two major enemies two major noises we
have to remove noises we know about
that's the sound from the loudspeakers
and noises we don't know about this is
the room noise the noises from
the street from across the street etc
etc
and happening that the noises from the
loudspeaker are the most difficult to
remove by two
reasons the first is that they are loud
gamers tend to listen to very loud
noises
sure nice levels which you can barely
hear your own thoughts
and in addition those noises are with
very broad spectrum they are like a
brick wall
else in frequency domain which means
that
you it's a it's a fair game you cannot
do any cheating you have to
find an algorithm which can remove them
and uh so you've been working on my
multi-channel uh echo acoust
acoustic echo cancellation since 2007
and in hindsight
it's turned out to be very important for
microsoft what drew you to this area
honestly uh
doing a multi-channel or stereo acoustic
echo cancellation is a very difficult
problem
even the inventor of the acoustic echo
cancellation from bellaps
in 1998 wrote a paper stating that it is
not possible to
create an acoustic stereo acoustic echo
consolation
since then there was a lot of creative
research in that area
and at the time it was quite challenging
so
we sit and we created a surround sound
acoustic echo cancellation which was
demonstrated during microsoft research
tech fest in 2008
and it was interesting coincidence that
the 30 seconds
movie clip we use it was from the launch
of xbox
at that time i had no information about
the
kinect device and what is cooking in
xbox team
but notice that during techfest a
colleague of mine whom i know it's a
principal architect in xbox team
started to bring more and more and more
people this is when i met for the first
time alex keep on without even knowing
that
he is actually behind a new and very
interesting and challenging device
a couple of months later i finished my
book which was nights
and weekends project and decided that
okay now it's time to return back to do
more interesting and cool research and
then alex kipman came and literally
drafted me to provide a set of
technologies the multi-channel acoustic
cancellation the microphone array
processing for a new device which at
that time was called project natal
yeah and so this also uh ended up in the
uh the product round table was that uh
before connect
roundtable was my first project in
microsoft research at that time it was
called ringcam
this is when i started to work for the
first time on
beamforming technologies on sound source
localization
technologies and i gathered a very
interesting experience actually
starting from doing research and ending
with finalizing a product
and that helped a lot for the technology
transfers i did later
yeah and so uh on the original connect
um how long did you work on that project
was it uh
a multi-year project so for
kinect we i started to work around
august 2008 and we shipped it in
november 2018
in 10. so it looks like around two
years and two months and during that
time
i had the challenging task to convert
our working
research algorithms into algorithms that
can
encode that can work in an industrial
environment in a device which is going
to be released
in in millions and then uh you
also worked on the new connect for xbox
one what
did you learn from the first xbox that
you took on to the xbox one project
so with all that the microphone array
and the audio design
for xbox one is going to be relatively
easier
because we already gathered a lot of
experience
working on kinect device the practice
always proves
us wrong when you believe that the next
step will be easier
so it happened that the microphone array
in xbox one
is way more challenging acoustically the
microphone array is
out of the device it's separated and the
the depth camera itself has enormous
acoustical influence
the depth camera in the xbox one is a is
a little bit bigger
so we have two cooling fans near my
precious hyper super sensitive
microphones
and this is what basically justified
taking the microphone array out of the
device so it's a separate block when you
see
the microphone and connect
in xbox one you see the two distinct
blocks the microphone array and the
device and the depth camera
but that camera is sufficiently big to
do some
sound reflections and this causes a lot
of problems fixing here or there and
making the microphones
to capture the sound properly and of
course we
have a lot of improvements in the
algorithms which process the signals
from those four microphones
and provide a better quality sound which
means
enable uh the
user the dashboard and the gaming
designers
to do more interesting scenarios more
challenging
games more interesting speech
recognition capabilities
so xbox has a reputation for delivering
lean efficient computations for its
system leaving all the power to the game
developers
you know what does that challenge look
like for you
so i still believe the xbox team was
and is one of the best engineering teams
we have in microsoft
the problem i have to face is that
those are enormously highly trained
software engineers
all the procedures for creating
debugging and building the code
establish it and follow it strictly
but not one of them
had for xbox kinect experience
doing audio signal processing code which
means that
they have difficulties to find the
problem
when it is not a coding problem when it
is algorithm
algorithmic problem and this is what
basically forces me to go
and to spend my first the four months
before
xbox kinect release there i had office i
had desk there i was working hand by
hand
and shoulder by shoulder with the
software engineers and what we tried to
do
for the xbox one is to bring
people with the proper qualification so
now the audio team in xbox
consists of four people with phds in
signal processing so
at least for me is way easier to work on
new algorithms and to hand over the
the matlab scripts and they can convert
and debug and solve most of the
uh the problems uh which are specific
for this particular implementation
so in addition to shipping products and
your research you've done 70 research
papers
multiple books and you're listed on 40
patents
how what what is your uh what what does
your day look like
that you've got your time split between
research
shipping products and doing academic
things like research papers and books
how to say xbox kinect converted my nice
and cool research office into one of the
focal points of a multi-billion dollar
business
yeah and this means a lot of people want
to
came over and to talk and to discuss the
problems with their new projects or
their new products
and especially with the trend of
converting microsoft from
software initially then software and
services and now devices and services
program
are the demand for audio processing
algorithm for sound capturing algorithms
for good systems
increase it because in most of the cases
those devices are small
they don't yet they don't have keyboard
they don't have mouse
so speech and speech recognition is one
of the most convenient modalities which
means good microphones and good speech
enhancement
so most of my day goes emails
and meetings so the two or three hours
at the end of the work day is my time
when i can do some creative work
yeah you left academia for microsoft
research years ago any regrets with that
you know i never regretted that
because it's one thing to teach your
students
on how to do engineering and it's
completely different to have
impact a real impact on how people live
enjoy their time entertain themselves
play games and from this standpoint
microsoft gave me the opportunity to
make that
impact and unlike my years as a
professor in the technical university
when
i know i was a good professor i prepared
a lot of good
engineers but you cannot measure the
impact now i know exactly how many
people are using my algorithms in
xbox connect for example so it's not
very often i get to spend some time in a
room that's been calibrated
tell us a little bit about this room and
what you use it for
so this room is the technical term is
unequivocal chamber
which means that there are two things
happen here
first looking at those edges
this means the sound does not reflect it
just gets absorbed
so we don't have reverberations the
sound you hear
is just the direct path from my mouth to
your ears or to the microphone of the
camera
and the second is that it's a quiet
place one when you close the door
this is a concrete cube which does not
touch the building
anywhere else than the floor and we sit
on this thick layer of rubber
so we don't pick the vibrations from the
building and from the street
and when you are in a quiet and
non-reverberant place
this is not a typical sensation for the
human brain
so first we are kind of used to hear
reverberation especially the one
which is the reflection from the ground
this is a cue for distance for us
and actually when you came closer uh at
some point the human
ear and series and brain will start to
sense this is a two different
sounds and this is the when the alarm
bell triggers
because this means the sound source is
already closer than the critical
distance in its
either your dinner or you're the dinner
of that yeah yeah
and the second is the uh so from this
standpoint we're kind of hanging in the
air
somewhere very high and we're not birds
humans are not three dimensional
creatures they're
two and a half dimensional creatures the
second is
silence and our brain is used to get
information from the external world from
sensors from ears from eyes from
all of our senses and suddenly one of
them does not give anything
so it starts to increase the attention
towards that sense in
after a couple of minutes you start to
hear
in your ears that's the blood in your
vessels after two three minutes you
start to hear your heartbeat and
body the sounds from your body how
you're breathing and you
start to hear more and more of those so
on
on reddit people say after like 45
minutes in nanako chamber you go crazy
anything to that not exactly crazy but
you start to have so-called
acoustical hallucinations because the
brain is a pattern matching machine
and the noise contains everything so at
some point it will be matched to
something you have heard and the brain
will classify this
and nothing more than that it's not that
scary but
it's not a pleasant actually sensation
and what's the longest that you've
you've spent in here
i have spent hours here but uh
pretty much doing something there are
always sounds of the equipment
instrumentarium the
the loudspeakers so i never basically
spent let's say one hour on purpose
laying on the floor
in complete silence we'll try that next
we can and so you've got a connect set
up here with a kind of a weird
uh u-shaped apparatus around it what is
this used for
so stepping aside from this information
deprivation
etc etc this anechoic chamber is an
acoustical measuring device what we have
here
is a arc with uh radius of one meter
with 16 load speakers on it and actually
you can see that there are also
16 microphones so this device can be
used for measuring directivity patterns
of microphones
and radiation patterns of loudspeakers
so in this particular case we have a
microphone array a kinect device
in the center of this semicircle
so the motors can basically move
the the arc and
at each position you place certain
sounds from the loudspeakers and record
them with the microphones
and after 400 measurements which takes
around six minutes
we can actually draw the directivity
pattern of the microphones
of kinetic of the kinect device in three
dimensions and then
use those to make our beamformers to
perform better and to suppress the
unwanted sounds better
and in the same way you can put in it
has been done actually
the last microsoft surface device and to
measure the directivity patterns of the
loudspeakers
and to see how we can direct the sound
more towards the
human which means less power and to
save some battery life etc etc so it's a
acoustical measurement tool nothing more
than that
yeah what will customers experience with
the new uh acoustic work in xbox one
with increase in developing this whole
story and
transforming xbox the challenges in
front of the sound capturing and speech
recognition and the speech enabled
dialog system raise it enormously
it's one thing to recognize xbox play
xbox stop
etc etc means a small set of commands
and it's completely different
to use speech recognition to select one
of
50 uh games one of three hundred
thousand
songs or one of uh hundred thousand
movies
and this requires way higher quality of
the capturing of the captured sound
so we can allow the speech recognizer to
do its own job so the sound isolation
also it helps with phone calls and
making sure
you hear people well but it also works
for the computer
to isolate and better understand that's
correct that's correct communication
scenario is one of them but
way more challenges for us now poses
having a speech recognizer to recognize
a large amount of words and to provide
the proper
out input to the user
and what's your next challenge at
microsoft
i mentioned that that the transition
from
software and services to devices and
services company
poses a lot of new challenges there are
a lot of new projects
going on always there is a microphone on
loudspeaker
engaged and of course what we want to
bring is
to make the user interfaces of our
computers to be
more human-like more native
more uh intuitive and this means
understanding better
humans who is talking what is the
emotional state
uh how many people are they when they
talk to each other when they talk to the
machine
can the computer interject in uh in the
conversation with something
meaningful and useful for the for the
company for the party
etc etc all of those questions
one way or another they go through the
microphones and loudspeakers because
the most native way we communicate
between each other is actually human
speech
great well thank you so much for having
us over today you're very welcome